there are enough people finish that we
can reenter the next theme okay so this
is what I let me explain ok so I told
you this is an experiment right so the
first aspect of my experiment was I
wanted to see after nine not actually
nine games actually 27 games right I
wanted to see if all of the scores would
start to progress to more three I
wondered if after playing for a long
time you start to work out tricks and
you can consistently tie all the games
now I've got problems we're trying to
draw a conclusion because I've got you
know particular particular data sets
which are armed yes yeah usually anyway
that was just the first time I
experiment okay the second part art
requires you to actually get a clean
sheet in front of you okay I'm because
this in some sense is actually the real
part of the game okay now you might have
wondered why what does it look like so
this is what I would why does it look
like a su doku then white why is it 3 by
3 and white like why not just have a you
know all of them down the page why they
separate the reason why is because this
is actually each each 3 by 3 is actually
its own game right this is a board for
game not called tic-tac-toe that called
ultimate tic-tac-toe now let me explain
Shh let me explain the way it works okay
because you do need to concentrate and
this is what the real thing about this
rumor is okay so how does detect
homework well usually for instance
suppose I'm just going to play against
myself okay um I might want to start off
and put an X there okay and then the
next player would you know doing you
would go and see what happens okay but
an ultimate tic-tac-toe it is a bit like
Sudoku so all of these squares these
nine are three by three squares they all
relate to each other okay so how do you
just play it in this middle square the
next player the the naught okay is now
not just up to not free to choose
wherever they won play they have to play
in the middle board okay so now the mort
is going to go somewhere in here okay so
for instance as
suppose I put my mark here okay now the
next play the next play is going to be
in this point so that X can choose where
to go just make sense stay with me stay
with me okay so the X might play here so
the knot is next going to go over here
okay now fast forward a little bit okay
the way to win ultimate tic-tac-toe is
to get not three squares in a row but
three boards in a row okay so I need to
win for instance suppose this is how
this game played out or something I
don't know whatever okay circles not
didn't do a good job over here okay so
now this board belongs to the X okay now
what that means is this board can be
played on anymore so suppose I'm now
down in here stay with me if I am in
this board right and I'm the x-ray and I
play here okay because this board that
corresponds to a board which are this
square corresponds to a board which is
over right now the lucky player here is
naughts can actually choose wherever
they want to go because that that boards
gone okay so I could if I wanted to I
Drive in Tokyo and so on okay so you can
imagine right this changes things a
little bit right you don't just want to
play to win a board you want to play to
manipulate the other players moves to
put them onto a certain board may be
where you want a disadvantage in or
whatever ok so if those of you who've
already played your nine rounds if you
play your night rounds find someone to
pair out with now I don't know how many
so you stands for arm you stands for
ultimate okay now because an ultimate
game takes so much longer okay what I'm
going to do is um rather than it being
zero points for a loss 1.4 tie because
you can still tie two points from with I
learn about to play it by 10 ok because
it's if you think about it it's mark its
nine squares right so almost I just
think x no it's too hard so if you win a
game or two tic-tac-toe right seeing a
single game ok that gives you 20 points
ok if it's a tie between the two of you
over the whole set
odds that's 10 points each and give up
the idea okay this makes it so if you've
done your I rounds get a piece of paper